almost everyone had at least at one
point in their lives that one important
challenge game that they really have to
win you know you need that one win to
win the medal or to get the prize money
or to achieve a certain norm but not a
lot of people had the opportunity to
play a chess game for their life so I
found this interesting article on
history collection and I found it on a
number a lot of places as well it says
that AUSA Bernstein the chess master was
arrested by the Bolshevik secret police
in 1918 and here you can see a Bernstein
was ordered shot because he was an
advisor to bankers as the firing squad
lined up to and burn his life a superior
officer asked to see a list of prisoner
names he recognized Bernstein is a great
chess master of the previous decade the
officer told Bernstein to play him a
game of chess and if he wanted life
would be spared
birds can beat the superior officer
quickly and she was released a free man
so this this seems like an amazing story
and although I would really like to
believe that this happened I don't know
I checked on chess Gamescom and we have
here in 1918 Bernstein has only one game
played and I put against the world
champion Alexander Alexander Alekhine
so what's troubling here is that if this
really did happen and I don't know if
it's happened to me and I got released
I'm pretty sure I would show someone
this game someone would probably have
this game written somewhere or published
it somewhere and since there is no and
there I couldn't find any evidence that
this game was ever played I don't know
this story this story doesn't really
doesn't really seem plausible what I'm
trying to say that it may have happened
and the Internet is a big place so
I'm sure that if this did happen some of
you probably have this game written
somewhere or you know where this game
can be found and if this did happen I
would very much like to see this game so
if anyone knows anything more about this
I would I would ask you to send you this
game or at least tell me where I can
find it
so because it's something like this did
happen this is the this is an amazing
story of chess of just history so yeah
that's it thank you for watching and
season